I started out with the it's the cut the
rope thing yeah Julie Coolidge I told
her you might want to check that out I
like Temple Run that's a fun game and I
like Angry Birds was kind of sticky for
a fruit ninja on Temple Run it wouldn't
really pick up my movements like I would
do something and it wouldn't get it but
it does pick up like when I wouldn't you
tap does it work it's nice that I has
all the apps already loaded on it the
battery life was interesting it only
charged up to 89% and I'm pretty sure
this was a new device we had to kind of
plug it in a lot I like how it comes
with games it's easy to hold it's easy
it's less easy to drop if they broke it
it's $150 for the price I think it's
probably worth it I think it was yeah
really good yes it was